welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Loki
season 2 episode 5 science fiction The
Season's penultimate episode that lets
go of the science and Embraces the
narrative fiction of giving your hero a
purpose to be a pen and a mug from Real
World alcatra has Mysteries to the
possibility that Loki could have
actually invented the TVA and B15
confirmed as Varity Willis let's break
down all the Easter eggs and amazing
attention to detail in this episode by
the way it means so much to me that you
watch these every week and you're
getting as much out of the series as I
am you can tell from my bloodshot eyes I
am recording this late after watching
the episode but if it freaks you out
just like cover your eyes until an asset
covers me like uh see you can't see my
eyes at all anyway thank you thank you
thank you for watching oh by the way I
am wearing our OB inspired shirt we're
all going to die I think it's my
favorite shirt that we've ever released
and really it's the best way to support
us by grabbing one of these you can get
it at nerd rot. shop and if you're in
the LA area we are doing a live show on
Thursday November 16th at brain dead
Studios come hang out with me with Tommy
with others from the new rock stars team
I'm going to have to face music for
thinking that mobus was McDonald's Jack
or theorizing that the TVA has got some
soilent green operation going on it's
going to be a lot of fun come hang out
with us okay we open the episode with
the Marvel Studios Fanfare with these
odd Sounds playing over
it now last week composer Natalie Holt
tweeted that for episode 4 she used
Whispers And vocal chants from the old
Norse poetic Eda locaa the locaa
features Loki the mythological Loki
accusing the gods of moralistic sexual
impropriety sorcery and bias which he
believes will lead to the onset of
Ragnarok but at the start of this
episode it's Loki who finds himself on
the other side of an apocalyptic event
Left Behind alone at the TVA as if on
the other side of a Rapture episode 4
ended with Loki getting flooded in light
from the wall of the temporal radiation
rushing toward toward the loom
observation deck but episode 5 opens in
the same moment with Loki's eyes opening
and Tom heston's blue eyes looking way
greener than usual while the temporal
Loom looks pretty messy on the left side
here it is not nearly as chaotic as it
was at the end of episode 4 remember
then the right side of the Loom was
completely unraveled but here the right
side looks pretty tightly braided to the
immediate right of the ring at least for
a bit until it starts to unravel further
down on the right side so we're not at
the exact moment of the Meltdown we are
before it but where is everyone well
they call this TVA code 1229 fail safe
mode so when the loom fails and temporal
radiation swamps the TVA I think what
this means is the TVA automatically
reverts all employees back to their
Branch timelines and freezes this
facility in a moment just before the
Meltdown gets really bad as it undergo a
rebooting process which would require
everything to spaghettify I think this
is just part of the tva's programming
why does the TVA need to do this it's
kind of like the blue screen to death
you're fail safe mode on your your
computer you know it's done so at that
point this is all so that the TV can get
rebooted and start over the variants are
reverted to their Branch timelines and
yes we see that each of those four are
on branched timelines allowed to exist
temporarily like external hard drives
waiting to be plugged back in to a
future iteration of the TVA but why was
Loki left behind here in this Rapture I
believe Loki as a variant to Sylvie
represents a kind of glitch in The
Matrix that is linked with sylv's
possession of he remains Master temp pad
Loki's time slipping I believe is
connected to her having that object as
OB later says it's like you're a better
version of one of those Tamp hats a
better version of one of those temp pads
is what he remains had the end credits
of every episode is on that thing and I
think that's why when Sylvie shoved Loki
out of the Citadel in season 1 episode 6
Loki inadvertently time slipped to an
earlier era of the TVA when we started
in season 2 episode 1 and a big clue
from the writers later in this episode
points to that device being the key to
everything we get a few match cuts of
Loki walking through the TVA kind of
lost and he's always Center frame on the
cut almost like a time slip that happens
without the slipping part of it it's
just on the cut and even though Loki is
headed in the opposite direction from
the automat we next cut to him walking
through the automat doors to find an
empty automat and all the cases that
used to be lit up with slices of keyme
pie are now all empty and dark I kind of
feel like we're watching Dany on the big
wheel going through the Overlook Hotel
he just kind of cuts from the kitchen
basement level to suddenly being in the
hallway with the Grady twins it's all
very very creepy L hears this
announcement TVA code
1229 fail safy initiated the weird thing
here is that it has this theramin music
playing underneath it recalling the
similar music playing under the Mis
minut welcome video like why would they
announce it at all if the whole point is
for people not to be in the TVA who is
this for I think it really is just part
of the programming and the TVA just kind
of runs on these weird pointless
courtesies so Loki Time Slips into a
Chrono monitor Bay and sees another
version of himself flipping through the
TVA handbook and then time slips again
and we realize he's just back a few
minutes because he returns to the bay to
find himself now reading the handbook
and the version of himself that he just
was is now behind him so we are seeing a
little old bootstrap Paradox tie itself
into a knot here and I love it upon
hearing his past self call out hello
before disappearing our Loki still looks
around confused and is like hello it
just kind of shows how sad and lonely
this Loki is he just wants someone to be
in the room with him but it doesn't last
long because the whole Chron monitor Bay
spaghettify and actually listen close
the
[Applause]
sound yeah maybe the reason The Shining
was in my head is that we hear these
weird screams mixed into the sounds that
sounds like the unnerving shrieks that
we hear over the opening titles of The
[Music]
Shining and since what is spaghetti fine
are these control panels the strands
take on a variety of colors to match the
wiring inside of those panels then the
TV monitor spaghett ifies cracking the
screen as it switches to a depiction of
Miss minut saying thank you for your
service before it switches off again a
pointless courtesy who is this for now
the opening Loki title does something
different this week while the letters
flicker through different type faces the
L disappears and then the K disappears
and then the I and then leaves the O by
itself and then all four letters appear
again but it mirrors how Loki gets left
behind by his friends but then reunites
with them by the end of this episode but
on to my favorite reveal this week that
Casey originated as Frank Morris alcatra
inmate AZ 1441 who famously escaped from
alcatra prison the island in San
Francisco Bay in June 1962 along with
Clarence England and John England using
papier-mâché dummy heads in their beds
the three climbed down ventilation ducks
that they carved into their cell walls
and went through an unused utility
quarter and then were able to get off
the island with an inflatable raft and
they were never found they were believed
to have drowned but there's been a lot
of public speculation that they got away
so like the DB Cooper incident in season
1 I love that loky season 2 brought up a
real life mystery and Justified it as an
extracted variant and maybe I'm just
obsessed with this because I live in San
Francisco I see alcatra every day and
just 6 weeks ago I visited alcatra
prison and I went on the audio tour
where they walk it through how Frank
Norris and how the angland broke out
Frank Morris had actually previously
escaped from the Louisiana State
Penitentiary and had an IQ of 133 so
that could explain why Casey is so into
the TVA guide book Frank Morris ended up
in Alcatraz for theft it's just worth
noting that Casey had been keeping a
drawer full of treasures in the TVA
though he considered most of those
Treasures junk and paper weights
attention to detail on this Prison Break
is so great the paper mâche head in the
beds the tiny tiny cell the hole that
they carved into the walls ventilation
shaft the boat horn that you hear from
outside and the Golden Gate Bridge in
the distance and his conspirators
Clarence angland and John angland are
actually cameos by Aaron Morehead and
Justin Benson who directed this episode
and other episodes of Loki season 2 they
and Eric Martin and kasarani are mostly
to thank for this season of content
being so good so Casey Frank tells them
let go hurry up if they catch us they're
going to cut us like fish ah it's a call
back to season 1 episode one when Loki
threatened Casey give me the Tesseract
or I'll G you like a fish Casey what's a
fish which at the time seems like a
reference to the movie Scream when the
killer told another character named
Casey you hang up on me again I'll gut
you like a fish understand but we see
that Loki has time slipped onto this
beach and they ask if he's the boat guy
and ky/ Frank says that he's in the
wrong place they could be referring to
the fourth conspirator of the June 1962
alcat escape a guy named Alan West who
had failed to escape and remained on the
island or it could be that the way these
three escaped is that they could have
synced up with an actual boat from the
mainland who would have picked them up
from the raft and taken them to Angel
Island which is where they were
intending to go so from here Loki slips
to the McDonald's parking lot in
Brockton Oklahoma 1982 and then the
parking lot of a piran of power sports
or Mobius works and we later find out
that's the year 2022 where we'll come
back to later but it might be just to a
coincidence but it is worth noting that
four of these characters have origin
years ending in two Casey's in 1962 sylv
in 1982 b15s in 2012 and Mobius is in
2022 Obi kind of spoils it by being in
1994 Loki then briefly Time Slips to
time theater 25 it's a large two small
five this episode is season 2 episode 5
so there's that but more importantly
this is the time theater where Mobius
first interrogated Loki in season 1 it's
where Mobius showed Loki the film re of
his life on the sacred timeline where
Loki was sobered by seeing the deaths of
frigga and Odin and himself it's a
hugely important location for Loki on
his journey it's where Mobius gave him a
second chance to have a new glorious
purpose as Loki says later you saw
something in
me that I hadn't seen in myself and we
know from Trailer footage that some
emotional gut punch scene is going to
take place here in the finale episode so
next we see B1 15's origin as a Dr
Willis pediatrician in New York New York
in 2012 and in the closing credits in
her file we see a photo copy of her ID
confirming her full name as Verity
Willis pediatrician and just to verify
that this isn't a random thing we also
see on that ID the name of her father
Roger Willis this is a huge confirmation
Varity Willis comes from the agent of
Asgard run of the Loki comics in 2014
bar Willis is part of a family that
includes her father Roger Willis that
was tasked with guarding the casket of
ancient Winters and the anvar not which
is a magical ring that allows the wearer
to see through any lie but when Verity
was a baby she eats this ring it
dissolves in her stomach it gives her
powers and later as an adult she meets
Loki while speed dating and Verity is
really the only character who can put
Loki in his place so this is perfect for
B15 it would make sense why she's such a
damn good hunter and why that she knows
this girl with the cast is probably
going to keep climbing trees do I think
the character that WM masaku played in
The Sacred timeline dissolved in as ring
in her tummy no probably not but I think
it is the spirit of the character that
they're trying to say is what B15 is now
again we're in New York City in 2012 in
the MCU uh don't you think it's
inevitable that we would hear explosions
or chitari yelling at each other
leviathans flying overhead this would be
Prime season for battle in New York
every other time we go to New York New
York in 2012 we're going to hear some
boom booms at some point we do not see
or hear the battle here but we are in a
branch timeline it could be a branch
where the battle never happened I think
it is though and we're going to end up
back in that battle and vity Willis is
going to do something awesome to help
people during it it's just pretty funny
that B15 Verity Willis would have been
impacted by a city-wide crisis caused by
Loki and that after she got pruned she
was the arresting officer of Loki
variant l1130 immediately after he
escaped from The Avengers after that
battle and she got to smack him across
the face Dr Willis says do you remember
how bad it hurt when you came in that's
good too yeah she tells the girl that
pain can actually be a good thing
because it teaches you how to avoid
danger in the future it's something B15
applies to Loki when she arrests him
slowing down that smack so that Loki
feels the pain every Nano second of it
but remember later in season 1 when
Sylvie meets with B15 in the rain
outside the rockard store and shows B15
her memories B15 cries and now we know
it's because she's a doctor and she's
probably thinking about all the kids she
wasn't around to care for p15d Willis
writes on the girls cast don't climb
trees and then she just realizes that's
not going to stop you is it the image of
climbing trees also showed up in TVA
propaganda posters as a metaphor for
pruning branches of the Sacred timeline
so we cut to Mobius AKA Dawn finally on
a personal watercraft but just kind of
he's not Ry a jet ski it is a SEO
recalling his line to X5 that not all
personal watercraft are jet skis now it
is interesting how Mobius remembers jet
skis as a TV agent but Casey didn't
remember what a fish was despite
paddling out across the San Francisco
Bay so Mobius is in Cleveland Ohio 2022
Branch timeline 202 22 would be 4 years
into the blip if the blip is part of
this Branch but you know what it sounds
like a great time for people to escape
their stressful life riding around on a
Seido on one of the many lakes rivers
and ponds in the state of Ohio I don't
know why people think they have to live
by an ocean to have a jet ski anywhere
where there's like a retention Pond of
water runoff from the rain you can have
a jet ski there's places in Nevada where
you can have a jet ski jet ski is an
American Dream my friend shut up now
this dirt bike Enthusiast who clearly
just wanted a free donut is played by
Isaac Bowman who's credited as the
cinematographer for loky season 2
episodes 1 3 4 and this one five between
this Cameo and Benson and Morehead
playing the Alcatraz guys it seems like
they gave these speaking roles to crew
close to production maybe to avoid
actors being cast in these roles and
listing them on their IM DBS which could
spoil it ahead of the Season that does
often happen lookie Time Slips directly
in front of the balloon guy matching his
goofy arm waving you can find old set
video of when they shot this with Tom
hon and it's pretty funny lover boys
working for the weekend plays on the
radio and we learned that Don is a
single dad with two sons a single dad
during the blip maybe his wife dusted in
the snap or maybe she fell off the back
of the SEO and he never turned around
cuz he was having too much fun but
remember Mobi got really defensive in
episode 2 When Brad brought up the
possibility that there were people
Mobius left behind on the sacred
timeline and even though he probably
didn't remember his kids maybe deep down
he had a fatherly Instinct and a kind of
guilt that had been haunting him so we
got to a bookstore in Pasadena in 1994
where a book titled the Zartan
contingent is on the shelf and it's
written by ad Doug PhD kqb
self-publishing we have seen the Zartan
contingent in the closing credits of
every episode its name could be a
reference to gi. Joe where Zartan is a
villain and mercenary who serves as a
leader of the dread knocks and works for
Cobra Commander he's a shape shifter
capable of changing his skin to blend in
but also in Marvel there is an ancient
alien race of shape shifters called the
Zartan with an X other books visible on
the Shelf atlas of Forgotten places by
Travis eloro explore the places That
Time Forgot but the age of spectacle by
Tom dof the ghost riter by Philip Roth a
story about a young woman with a vague
past who the main character comes to
believe is in in Frank Smiley People by
John lard that's a spy novel that's the
third in the series the first was Tinker
Taylor Soldier Spy the last Library by
Freya Samson Disclosure by Michael kryon
debt of Honor by Tom Clancy the big red
train ride by Eric newbie so Obie's
original name was ad Doug which
definitely seems like a nod to science
fiction writer Douglas Adams the author
of The Hitchhikers guy of the Galaxy who
cursed every reference to the number 42
in media thereafter so we learned that
OB or ad Doug has been trying to buy his
books with cash from bookstores so that
later when the bookstores would try to
figure out where the book came from to
be able to pay the royalties to the
publisher they'd think oh maybe we have
to order more of this book from this ad
Doug guy and then ad Doug would finally
make some money from all this it's kind
of clever but yeah doesn't work sneaky
sneak now behind the checkout counter
you can see some more books Men Are from
Mars Women Are from Venus by John Gray
overload by Arthur Haley that's
concerning the electricity production
industry in California and the
activities of the employees and others
involved with the Golden State Power and
Light which is a fictional California
Public Service Company insomnia by
Stephen King where the character can
perceive auras and other hidden things
Disclosure by Michael Kon and the windup
bird Chronicle by Haruki Mami thank you
to betterhelp for sponsoring this video
if you're spending hours at the gym
trying to get your body ready for the
stress of the holidays you might want to
think about putting the same work into
getting your mind ready for the stress
of the holidays and to do that you'll
want to get help from a licensed
therapist with better help starting
therapy can be hard the right therapist
for you might not be in your area and
some people struggle with the
face-to-face interaction of therapy with
better help you can have your therapy
sessions as a phone call as a video chat
or even via messaging if you prefer that
whatever is the most comfortable version
of therapy for you just click the link
in the description and answer a few
questions about what you're looking for
from therapy and what your preferences
are better help will then match you with
the therapist from their Network that's
right for you and if you don't really
fit with that therapist which is a
common thing with therapy you can easily
switch to a new therapist for no
additional costs without stressing about
insurance who's in your network or
anything like that mental health is
quite the journey but it is an important
one to start your journey towards better
mental health click the link in the
description or visit betterhelp.com neww
rockstars to help support this Channel
and get you 10% off your first month
with better help so ad goes back to his
Warehouse in the Hills outside Pasadena
since he's a teacher at Caltech this
structure would probably be part of the
jet propulsion laboratory which were
various facilities around the Pasadena
area used to experiment on Rocket
engines for NASA like on one of the
shelves are models for NASA space
shuttles this structure was probably
part of the jpl's jet engine testing but
this is the same exact room structure of
the RNA Department of the TVA it is the
same curved shelves the same overhead
pneumatic tube snaking down into a coil
like the Looms throughput multiplier so
what is going on did ad build the TVA up
around this Warehouse structure or when
he got taken into the TVA did he build
his Department to look like his old
workstation I think ad Doug was an
imaginative sci-fi writer and science
Professor who is in inspired by his own
book that was given to him by Loki and
he built the TVA as we know it starting
with this lab the computers in the TVA
all have early 90s black backgrounds
because that's a tech 80 had in 1994 so
in effect Loki was the kind of Godfather
of the TVA Obie is the one who built it
and then the Kang variant he remains
took it over that's where my theory
brain is at this week we see this
close-up of a Post-It note board oh my
God so we've seen this in the credits of
every episode except there is one new
blue Post-it that's been added right to
the middle that is not there in the
credits it's only in this scene and this
blue note reads right in the middle who
what where when why and the who is
circled it's already giving us the
answer that Loki later realized at the
end of this episode it's not about where
when
or
why it's about who now Brandon baric was
a huge help and identifying these
Post-it notes he made a helpful grid
with all 112 visible Post-it notes
labeled a lot of them are repeated on
other notes but I honestly think these
might have been story beats used by
headwriter Eric Martin while they were
writing this season of Loki and it was
repurposed as a prop with names and
other details swapped out so here's what
it says we can see Brothers duel it has
the upper hand L returns then crossing
the threshold then the thorn of
consequences then introduction of amulet
story Forks at this point so the amulet
could be their code word for he remains
Master Tad that could be the Nexus point
that the finale Loops back to in the
Citadel next poster note flashbacks from
book one dead lake at the heart of
something then hex moment and this is
underlined in red around pm. a feline
creeping up in the shadows Whispers
rustling a buildup and then an arrow
pointing to Crescendo and that's
underlined next of the silent Mountain
Dash and T move forward one says wrong
unsettled next continuity of an
ancestral pilgrimage dark mountains
Celestial alignment fated prophecy H has
an epiphany tests Bridge of Worlds the
broken Heron which could be not to Kate
Heron who directed the season one
episodes a curse passed down through
generations apprehensive double
underlined Dar leaves in the dead of
night monster Godlike Soul lineage
ancestors Trace back their Generations
expansiveness deceit double underline
Bridge of Worlds the broken Heron again
Ally in enemies death at amulets curse
the cracking of water ice he knows a
re-echoed sound multiple reflections of
the same sound cracks appear in fabric
of grotesque unhinged Decoy for the
hijack could the hijack be the hijacking
of that flight by DB Cooper H finds out
about her parents captivity the ground
Falls from under her feet a Falls
parallel secret of the dark mountains
urine's betrayal capture kidnapped
parents what circumstances what if the
golden scepter the third Moon T
Discovery changes everything which could
be a reference to lenes approach the
innermost cave fear Darkness kept in
dark and something crossed out a falls
behind loses te in the fog Forest nation
and something crossed out the broken
tree her inocence keeps her naive safe
unbeknownst to her his feet silent
creeping on the soft mosque covered
floor the who what where when why and
who is circled flaxi and calendar lunar
mortality and Grandeur expansiveness and
amplitude victory in the wings the truth
what does the monster represent hex
moment Zartan hidden Fort of Zartan tea
story parallel with Zartan in book two
the ordeal Arc of the her is something
sensitive something he feels something
more then pool of deception Vapor traps
in lungs initiates dream state parallax
Arrangements having nearly the same
energy dreams something feels wrong
unsettled urine unhinged fear Darkness
kept in the dark the reward parallactic
ellipse a parent ellipse as seen against
the background of Secret of the dark
Mountain the road back of Zartan at the
end of quest a quest Journey obstacles
hope sacrifice something must be given
up belladon space and Valley the boy
betrayed the tower keeper navigation
directional inter Jal something of
viewpoints switches flips perception
seventh world of the serpentine system
book of the something resonance
reflection reverberation the Mist
follows pull a deception be feels like
he's sinking time is slipping friend is
facing away a was in space in Valley
apparitions darish falling quiet pensive
softly spoken Dawn at the end resonance
pool of deception ancestry key point I'm
sure this will all make sense after the
finale so ad tells Loki of course I
believe you it's a dream come true one
of my characters has come to life and
needs my help this reminds me of what
happens in the sons of uran yes so uran
was a name mentioned on this board sons
of urine is apparently just another
fictional book that he wrote and maybe a
lot of these flat points are just made
up for whatever this story is
but for a second we suspect that
everything in the TVA might be taking
place in ad dg/ ob's imagination like
he's kind of like a Tommy Westfall
figure from the saint elsewhere finale
or this could be like the 2006 film
Stranger Than Fiction starring Will
frell as a guy who realizes he's a
character in a novel being written by
Emma Thompson's author character really
I just think that ad Doug has written
countless stories about this kind of
subject matter so that when Loki finds
him he is exactly the kind of thinker
who would turn the TVA into a reality
now in the mess of 8s books by the
typewriter is the book on black holes
that we've seen in the closing credits
Obie says that since time traveling in a
place like the TVA which is supposed to
have time is still possible to Loki then
traveling back to a place that doesn't
exist anymore is equally possible
doesn't sound like science no but it
does sound like fiction science SL
fiction is the title of the episode but
the punctuation doesn't merge the two
words together like the literary genre
of Science Fiction but it puts a slasher
between them making it an either or an
or a choice between looking at things
from a scientific perspective or from a
fictional perspective OB says with
science it's all what and
how but with Fiction it's why so Loki's
why at least at this point in the
episode is to preserve the TVA to
prevent what's coming he says but that's
not his real selfish why he can't yet
admit that it's not about the why it's
about the who for him it's about his
loneliness he needs to time slip for
someone in order to move when they
approach a chalkboard hanging on the
Shelf to the right is a 1922 New York
Giants baseball hat it's the same one
worn by kiway Quan a Short Round in
Indiana Jones at the Temple of Doom it's
such a sweet Easter egg and something
that you can celebrate with another
shirt on nerd rot. shop our Indie I love
you design the prod that ad zaps Loki
with looks like another piece of
technology that could have inspired
Victor timely's design for the time
stick ad Doug deduces that to reunite
all the people Loki cares about he would
need the knowledge to build a temp Pad
but Loki luckily has that TVA handbook
in his coat pocket so like Riner giving
Victor timely the book Loki gives ad
Doug slob the book and sets into motion
the origin of the original pre Kang TVA
Loki flips outside the home of dawnus
Don has twin Sons Kevin and Shawn played
by twins Caleb Johnston Miller and Blake
Johnston Miller there's a rope made of
tied bed sheets hanging from one of the
upstairs Windows I'm assuming it's
Kevin's and that Kevin had snuck out Don
notices an action figure that is burnt
and I'm pretty sure that is a TVA minute
man or a figure meant to look like one
it seems like Don's sons are a bit of a
Goofus and gas situation Goofus being
Kevin who gave you the matches I stole
them Kevin is total Sid from Toy Story
energy I'm going to assume he's actually
named after Kevin feige or Kevin the
robot because both of them are kind of
toy Masters who love to play with their
toys and then destroy their toys but I
think we can also see these boys as the
sons of Odin two rambunctious boys you
got a longer- haired Thor who just
breaks everything but then you also have
a calmer more responsible son who loves
snakes and Loki loves snakes if you keep
them from burning down the house I'll
get you a puppy and a snake Mobius tries
to sell Loki a watercraft again and Loki
recalls a beautiful Union of Form and
Function this is how mobus described jet
skis in season 1 episode 2 there was a
beautiful Union of Form and Function
which we call the jet ski if we are
learning that Loki truly did Inspire the
TVA now I'm wondering if this phrase
right now was first put into Mobius his
head from this conversation and
surprisingly fast OB appears through a
glitchy time door with a large prototype
temp pad actually you can see that he
wrote on this device temporal access
device he says that it took him 18
months well actually 19 months I had to
take a break and move out when I lost my
job and my wife left me oh no this
speaks to what it takes to be a Kang
level inventor you have to sacrifice all
your personal relationships Loki tells
Don to come with him your boys won't
even know you're gone yeah but I will
all of existence is in grave danger I
don't care Loki's pretty much learning
the lesson he needs to learn this
episode it is about the who without our
loved ones we are lost so lucky
reconnects with B15 drver Willis and
then with Casey Frank Morris who looks
like he's just watching up to Angel
Island in San Francisco Bay judging from
the angle of the Golden Gate Bridge
behind them that apparently was the
destination of these Scapes according to
investigators but then back at the
McDonald's and Brockton sy's take out
bags spaghettify as the camera passes it
and you can see in the side view mirror
of her truck that the process completes
and it is right in front of her face but
it doesn't really phase Sylvie I think
she knows little bits and pieces of her
reality are fading like this but she's
okay with it because she's got the
amulet she's got the master tin pad and
I think she thinks she can continue
staying a step ahead of this apocalyptic
event that's what she's been doing her
entire life after all this could also
explain why Sylvie unlike the others
remembers Loki I think her use of that
device and her connection to Loki have
made them sort of immune from the
effects that affect the others at this
bar there is a zaniac arcade game zaniac
grave blood yeah this is actually the
voice of Brad of Raphael cassol remember
his status as a BigTime actor from the
zaniac film series in the' 70s was on
the sacred timeline and if you stick s
around in this episode all the way to
the end of the credits you can hear his
voice again you died insert your coin
loser which kind of feels like a meta
nod to us like we're dead after watching
this episode he's calling us losers Loki
and Sylvie debate whether restoring the
TVA is ethical you would be ripping
people from their lives showing them
something that they cannot
unsee what kind of choice is that and
finally Sylvie gets what Loki really
wants out of this I want to save
everything all of it is it really that
hard come on keep trying I want to save
the TVA why I want the TVA back and what
do you want I want my friends back yeah
it takes the bartender whose name is
Eric and I wonder if he was named after
headwriter Eric Martin because it would
take the head Storyteller here to break
through to Loki to ask him what he wants
finally for Loki to give an honest
answer that answer is he doesn't want to
be alone Loki asks that without his
friends where does he belong and Sylvie
responds we're writing our own stories
now it's the deeper theme of this
episode The Power of story controlling
one's own narrative Loki begins this
episode poo pooing the idea of being a
writer but to truly run the TVA you have
to be a playright you have to learn the
elements of story and transition from
the god of Mischief into the god of
stories and the god of stories is what
Loki becomes when he returns to Varity
Willis in the agent of Asgard run behind
the scenes photos in the season 1
writers room showed that Michael Waldren
used Dan Harmon's Story Circle to
structure each episode and that follows
the Joseph Campbell monomyth cycle with
eight story beats you need go search
find take return change this episode
forced Loki to go back to steps one and
two of that cycle you and need who is
Loki and what does he need and this
scene ends with what seems like a gag
Sylvia had ordered two shots of bourbon
and drinks hers but when she leaves and
Loki reaches for his it's gone for a
second he thinks wait did she just drink
both of these no no no the reality is
it's spaghettified away and if you look
at sylv's eyeline she looks down she saw
it happen but she doesn't care this also
recalls the last time these two got a
drink on that train to sheru in season 1
episode 3 the whole love is a dagger
speech where the object disappeared out
of their hands in the record store
Sylvie visits there's a little monkey
toy now this is a vintage Japanese toy
that normally wears a little green
sombrero and strums the guitar and Taps
his little orange shoes so just another
example of green and orange green and
orange everywhere even in This Record
Store as the camera passes this monkey
on the left is an Edith PF record Edith
PF best known for the
song or no I regret nothing which is how
Sylvie feels now as much as I love Love
The Velvet Underground imagine the scene
hearing maybe it'd be too Inception I
guess now the shopkeeps coffee mug reads
take me and depicts an alien abduction
and from his orange coffee press the mug
the couch pillows sylv's green coat lot
of orange and green he recommends The
Velvet undergrounds loaded and Sylvie
plays the song oh sweet nothing which we
should note it's not the first song on
this album it is the last song and the
GU take me mug did disappear like an
alien abducted it it just spaghettified
along with the pat his spilling coffee
and everything in the shop and it looks
awesome like the song talking about
having nothing at all that is all that
is left after this all spaghetti pies
but Sylvie is not that worried she just
kind of swipes the temp pad amulet and
this orange time door opens and notice
how the strands are repelled from that
door so this technology which the
closing credits always end on really
seems to be the master technology that
is going to be the key to everything in
the finale it is the amulet maybe it's
even from ancient Egypt and that's why
she has those anky earrings I think that
Sylvie thought that wherever she was as
long as she had this text she could save
off any spaghettification effects but
she was wrong and that Spooks her into
rejoining Loki but it's too late like
the ending of Avengers Infinity War they
all fade one by one with tragic final
lines but I still didn't take it it was
a fiction problem now I have to go back
to see my boys
[Applause]
this there's nowhere left to go
sh and these final words echo in Loki's
head as he desperately tries to graph
the strands to cling to the pieces of
his friends but then he hears some lines
from even earlier from season 1 like
this you know where I go if I can go
anywhere this is what Mobius said right
before he got pruned in season 1 episode
4 you know where I go if I could go
anywhere and then Loki here also hears
this do you think that what makes a Loki
a loky is the fact that we're destined
to lose syv said this to Loki on lenus
in that same episode do you think that
what makes a Loki a
Loki is the fact that we're destined to
lose into this line Loki screams his
mouth going Curby wide and then he
figures it out I did
it I controlled it and Loki explains to
Obie it's not about where when
or
why it's about who he spins in the room
to look at his friends and he realizes
he knows how to rewrite the story and
smooth as silk he's back on the loom
observation deck with ob the moment they
watched Victor timley head down to his
death so what happened here like Desmond
and Lost season 4 in the constant
episode the one thing that grounds
someone who lost in time is their loved
one they're constant for Desmond it was
pen for Cooper and Interstellar it was
his daughter murf and for Loki it's
Sylvie and his friends why doesn't this
include Victor timley this episode well
I think Loki feels a unique kinship with
variants who were violent ly extracted
from their histories and forced to work
for the TVA as variants a kind of
chaotic confusion you only feel with
fellow grunts in the workplace so Loki
let's go with a science science that as
Guardians like Thor told Jane Foster is
just another word for magic and science
and Magic are two things that cannot be
controlled and Loki instead Embraces
something that can be controlled fiction
as a god of stories and every great
Story begins with the question who am I
now throughout the closing credits of
this episode notice how each name has
one letter drifting away the casting
director screen shows b15s confirmation
as vity Willis Mobius on the SEO Loki
turning around to see himself OB in his
lab and the mug shot of John angland and
Clarence angland the directors of this
episode Justin Benson and Aaron Morehead
now if you enjoy my Approach the movie
and TV analysis we just released what I
think is YouTube's most in-depth
analysis of John Carpenters the thing
over on the Deep dive Channel Please
Subscribe and watch that video and again
best way to support us is by grabbing
one of these OB we're all going to die
shirts at nerd right . shop see you at
our live show on November 16th in Los
Angeles subscribe to all three channels
of the new rockstars Network follow me
at eaos on all social platforms big
thanks to Brandon baric to Noah Chen and
gito for helping me with this breakdown
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
bye